que patrick ollier pour le groupe l'est
républicain merci monsieur le président
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre
les français ont montré leur unité face
au drame des attentats qui ont fait
après notre pays
mais en démocratie et l'unité nationale
autour de nos valeurs fondamentales
n'exclut ni le débat ni la prise de
conscience des réalités quotidiennes
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que les
français craignent pour leur sécurité
mais ils craignent aussi pour leur
emploi en octobre dernier le nombre de
demandeurs d'emploi atteint des records
quarante deux mille chômeurs de plus en
un mois c'est + 3 7 % en un an
aujourd'hui 5 millions sept cent
quarante huit français sont au chômage
ces 10 8% de la population et cela sans
compter les quarante deux mille huit
cents personnes qui ont été supprimés
administrativement à pôle emploi pour la
france ces chiffres sont une véritable
catastrophe humaine monsieur le premier
ministre
et ne vous réfugiez surtout pas derrière
l'héritage
car contrairement aux promesses répétées
de françois hollande contrairement aux
autres pays européens qui profitent de
la même conjoncture économique favorable
le chômage ne cesse d'augmenter en
france alors qu'en allemagne il est de
44 7% de la population soit la moitié
ne pensez vous pas que le coût du
travail supérieur chez nous dans le
secteur marchand à celui de concurrent
européen en soi une des causes de pensez
vous pas que les contraintes qui
paissent les entreprises rajouter aux
normes européennes que vous appliquez
avec beaucoup de zèle en soit aussi une
des causes
ne pensez vous pas que les errements de
vos orientations politiques successives
voire contradictoires en sont également
une des causes et empêche la confiance
nécessaire aux investissements des chefs
d'entreprise c'est donc bien vote
politique qui est responsable des
mauvais chiffres du chômage
alors monsieur prémices quand allez vous
revenir sur vos erreurs et faire preuve
de moins d'idéologie et de plus de
réalisme quand allez vous enfin changer
de politique
merci monsieur ollier la parole est à
madame la ministre du travail de
l'emploi de la formation professionnelle
dialogue social merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
députés monsieur le député patrick
ollier
oui les chiffres du chômage du mois
d'octobre après une baisse importante en
septembre ne sont pas satisfaisants oui
et ceux du mois de septembre n'avait
apporté aucun triomphalisme de ma part
que quelle est la situation actuelle
dans notre pays nous avons une
croissance qui est à 1,1 pour cent et ça
c'est un acquis il faut pour baisser
durablement le chômage
un deuxième préalable ce qui est des
créations nettes d'emplois en un an nous
avons cinquante mille créations nettes
d'emplois sauf que ce n'est pas
suffisant
en effet il ya une reprise de l'activité
économique
mais ce n'est pas suffisant justement
pour compenser notre défi démographique
c'est pour cela que nous continuons à
réformer vous parler du coût du travail
le pacte de responsabilité le cic eux
ont permis de réduire le coût du travail
en france
d'ailleurs dans l'industrie le coût du
travail est moindre par rapport à
l'allemagne
si nous portons cette réforme la réforme
du droit du club du travail d'ici 2016
chez justement pour permettre une
meilleure adaptation aux réalités
locales des entreprises par la
négociation collective
en effet il y a un besoin de
clarification du code du travail c'est
tout le sens du projet de loi parce que
la confiance des entreprises est là mais
malheureusement les chefs d'entreprise
restent trop prudent et les embauches
qui se font se font à travers des
contrats courts ou à travers l'intérim
est tout l'enjeu de cette réforme du
droit du travail
tout l'enjeu est également de la loi
portée par emmanuel macron vise à
redonner confiance à une entreprise et
comparons ce qui est comparable
s'agissant de l'allemagne vous savez
bien nous sommes pas dans le même défi
soit 100 milles départ à la retraite
dans les deux pays
mais six cent soixante mille entrées sur
le marché du travail en allemagne alors
que chez nous c'est 850 mille entrées
sur le marché du travail donc il ne faut
pas faiblir
il faut continuer et khoury nous
continuerons à réformer jusqu'au bois
merci madame la ministre pour le groupe
socialiste rapide